[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about
whatever we want [ __ ] don't you
know it
it's been so hot today i know and then
you guys are skateboarding
here's the thing i'm learning how to
surf and i heard that like
long boards are really good to learn how
to surf on
and bart has a long board and i never
knew why long boards
existed because they were boring i liked
riding it but i didn't know how to ride
at home or in there
you should try they have a surf
attachment for a skateboard i've seen
that wait
what it's a you attach it to the trucks
of your wheels
so then when you want to carve on it it
turns it super far i don't
i don't know so i'm so lame sorry i'm
kind of dead over here carve like when
you go like this
like on a skateboard you can kind of
turn like this oh yeah but then when you
lean on it with the attachment it lets
it like do
hard oh kind of like an actual surfing
yeah like oh
i've seen that like the wheel thing yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna take it you're
talking about like
on a on a regular skateboard like a
banana board or one of these guys there
not a normal skateboard
wow it's like an aggressive one yeah
okay it's
97 degree what is that like in
uh for all of our celsius fans like 37
or some [ __ ]
35 36 yeah that makes no sense to me
okay
it's too low of a number i like to see
big numbers me too i like to be like
america it's a hundred something degrees
fire mile over there it's like 37. it
looks like a bra
seven it looks like a bra it's a 38 like
you're a [ __ ] don't tell me it's one
third off tell me it's 33
off yeah oh [ __ ] that was the thing i
did like about living in mexico though i
was learning the metric system pretty
do you remember it i don't anymore okay
they're pretty metric-y over there yeah
do they use kilometer
yes did they drive on the left no no
they don't do that
every time i see that i get mad i was
watching the spacex launch and they said
something in kilometers and i was like
[ __ ] you what's it what's in miles man
yeah convert it for me you ho
[ __ ] and they get the same [ __ ] it's
kilos why
in the comp international competition oh
really we're the only losers i know
we're losers
i know that we're it's like dumber or
some [ __ ] but i don't care i'm part of
the dumber crew that got raised that way
so [ __ ]
teach me we're part of the dumber
superpower so
i don't know why i have to learn your
superior dumb [ __ ]
and i don't know why they uh scale drugs
in both
pounds grams ounces yeah that's
confusing
it is very confusing for all the drug
lords out there that are watching
animals annuals
and mules maybe you can tell me and
explain users too
why this is the thing that everyone uses
as like either pounds or kilos it was
the hardest thing i had to convert
how many grams in an ounce and then how
many ounces in the past that's not fair
why did they put you through that maybe
[ __ ] move drugs
like one metric system maybe it's the
drug
drug system's way to get people
back into math maybe oh because i didn't
learn
28 grams is an ounce 16 ounces is in a
pound
yeah oh i should sell drugs i don't know
any of that stuff
i don't know i never got to the kilo
level
how many kilo in a pound i don't know i
never got to that level
i know that only because of lifting see
lifting
brings you back to me because like when
i went to asia i was like i need to find
a gym everything's in kilos you have to
like
keep doing the math what is it like 2.3
pounds 2.2 2.2
did you ever feel so when i was like
when i was a kid
you know you always get taught like
you're only restricted
by your own self yep so when i started
lifting
i was like i only feel that it's heavy
because i know it's like 500 pounds i'm
like
load it up with some crazy amount that i
don't know and then tell me the kilo
number that i don't know
and i'll bet i'll lift it and i tried it
i almost broke my back
because i thought i was really right i'm
sorry
the kids in my gym class they bet me to
deadlift 300 pounds
and i did it but then i got stretch
marks like the next day
the next day well i think i already had
them but i didn't notice
and after i did this [ __ ] after i did
this [ __ ] i was like changing and
they're like yo you got stretch marks
and i was like what was that from
yesterday
were you a fat kid oh you're just tall
tall
i grew really fast i grew really fast
too
where'd you get the stretch marks you're
back on my back yeah i was like it
looked like i got whipped or something
but
they were like perfect lines they're
gone now i think so yeah
i mean yeah you don't get to see them
that much you can like see them
sometimes like because it's clear
they're clear now though you should get
like a butterfly tattoo or something
just a couple that's tight
oh butterfly tattoos have you been
seeing those
the new trend with tattoos now it's like
all red ink dragons and things like that
it kind of looks like that instagram
filter that people are putting on their
faces and [ __ ]
it's either black or red i've seen it
what about it
it's interesting it's an interesting
trend that's happening so i always love
tattoos like crazy right but there came
a time in tattooing revolution that
things changed like almost every month
like technology changed whatever changed
and then um i think like when you get
too into something
for some reason it doesn't become like
you become kind of critical of it you're
kind of like you're too like uh
you're a snob yeah yeah and i think that
it didn't entice my
eyes and heart the same way that it used
to so the so i'm kind of glad that i
didn't get more tattoos
yeah because i would have regretted it
in the yeah in
in in ways wishing that i used the skin
space for something else
there's some sick [ __ ] out there dude
you have a lot of skin space too
i know but now i can't make a decision
it's so crazy and i have these shitty
tattoos
it's like our old tattoo but he's a
tattoo artist with like one tribal arm
and i i didn't get why he did that but
then now it makes sense to me
because i every time i look now
nothing's good enough
it just feels weird because it's not
like oh i know what the pain feels like
i can deal with that
it's now it's just a design thing i know
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be married with this idea
every single time i like an idea a week
goes by it's done
the reason why i haven't ever gotten a
tattoo because i really wanna experience
what it feels like
like i just wanna know what it's like oh
get a little frog
but the the design though and the
placement i'm like
what if i hate this and do it on your
palms and it'll go away
oh and really because these shed yeah
this and the bottom of your feet so do
it and
go in like three years that's what i was
gonna tell you um so if you're looking
at the artists right like they're all
pretty good and they don't get sharper
like
the art still is relatively the same
it's just the technique kind of switches
up a little bit
but what's gonna happen within like five
to ten years maybe even 20 30 years your
skin quality changes so so does the
tattoo so it doesn't matter how dope
or crisp or sharp it is it's all going
to turn dark fated
yeah it's a [ __ ] just get it no it's
not really that it's the it's the trend
the art
the skill it just keeps getting better
and changing and then with technology
new shit's coming out with the
politicians [ __ ] doesn't change
what new [ __ ] is coming out that you've
seen like what's changing
people's skills like they keep pushing
the bar
so like now you have straight up
trained artists that are doing like
murals and crazy things and nico dude
for some odd reason like they know how
to make things look like
3d now and then now i'm just like whoa
because my standards were here when i
was into it
and now they're here and then now it's
just kind of
it's a whole different world and it
keeps changing so every time i keep
going back like whoa this is some new
[ __ ]
it's almost like um maybe if you're like
into cars or something there's like new
technology new things like if the car's
a car
but then it just keeps changing for me
when i was a kid i was in the sidewalk
chalk
that was sick but now that [ __ ] is next
[ __ ] level they can make it look like
you're 40 stories above where you're at
and you're like oh [ __ ] i'm walking on
the sidewalk but i'm like i'm getting
chills
that's so true it looks like i'm gonna
fall yeah
with with the tattooing so like back in
the day what they used to do is they do
the outline right
and they shade in the outline now you
have all these professionally trained
people so they do it the actual art
theory way
so they finish literally from corner to
corner
so it's once they go from here to here
all of this is done they never go back
what and they keep going this way and
everything that's here it it just moves
down like this i thought they had to
like go back because your skin needs to
heal a little bit so
no not if you have one of these guys
like the guys that are like
traditionally
trained i mean uh like a true artist
yeah classic artist that's how they do
it
if you go to i mean some styles just
like the japanese style that's just
based off old traditions
so that's gonna be an outline no matter
what but the new like black and grades
type stuff right people that are really
good
they go like from here and then all the
way down it's like this is one of the
guys that i like
i don't know if i could show it this way
but that's nico so nico's one of the eco
is pretty good
that goes literally from one side all
the way to the other and it's fit once
he's done he's finished yeah
okay that's what's crazy is like they'll
do
like the last supper and back in the day
it probably
looked like the last dinner they're all
weird in there yeah you know their hands
are all like
it looks like party city last summer
yeah yeah last summer yeah yeah the last
supper used yeah it looked like a
cartoon
but then now it just looks like
one of the ninja turtles did the work on
their back you know like leonardo or one
of those guys
oh that's it looks legit leonardo's a
very good drawer
and then there's also like the [ __ ] that
looks like a computer did something on
you like a 3d
crazy shape it's weird they have that
right the 3d printed
or like a printed tattoo i think i've
seen that like well i think they'd print
onto a transfer
and then they and then the humans doing
that after yeah so there's they still
have
machines doing essentially yeah dude
imagine having an incredible hulk tattoo
from like the 70s or some [ __ ] and then
you see this new [ __ ] you're like oh
[ __ ] you kidding me
that's what's dope i feel like it aged
with you so now it's just a piece of
like
a memory i think it's dope you know what
else is aged nothing i don't have a good
smooth transition but this video
is brought to you by upstart
okay so during these economically
turbulent times everyone is looking for
a way to feel
more financially secure and there's a
lot of us that have credit card debt i
know especially right out of college
um you know you just don't you're not in
the best financial situation so you do
have a bunch of credit cards open some
things you use to buy clothes some you
use to buy
books some you use to spend on just your
college expenses
or only fans or only fans and the
interest rates are all
you know all through the roof and it's
really hard to get a hold of your
finances especially when trying to get
your life in order
which is why upstart is super awesome
because they can reward you not just
based off of your
uh credit score but based off your
education and job history in the form of
a smarter rate
and if you can consolidate all of your
debt into one payment
that helps you keep track of things and
you could get back on your feet much
easier i'm actually going to do this
today and i'll tell you guys what i
qualified for
because i have a strategy so i have
about um
14 000 on a credit card right
and it had the credit card is zero apr
but it's gonna go
the promotion for zero apr it's gonna go
up in november
so i'm like what if i just move it on
over to upstart if they have a smaller
apr
then whatever the credit card is
probably going to be 16 or something
but if hey man i'll do that i'll [ __ ]
throw that
dead insert into here yeah i mean it's a
strategy of mine because i would rather
use that 14 000
right now on crypto because [ __ ] is
blowing up
so what cy upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot and hurry up to
upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be checking your rate only
takes a few minutes
that's upstart.com record
record thank you upstart that's true
i'm legit gonna go and do that
afterwards uh
man there's a lot of things happening
right now let's give a big
thank you to the crypto gods boosting up
omisego
thank you very much network let's go oh
it went from one dollar
to what six dollars oh in three days
i finally broke even after all these
years god damn remember when we were
doing uh live shows and people were like
crypto's a big scam
yeah up yours pal it's only a scam if
you lost money [ __ ]
you cashed out the wrong time that's the
problem with a lot of people
um they get emotional and the minute
they
see their shares dipped they're like i
gotta jump ship and he starts selling
but that's when you lose money
technically if you own a thousand shares
and even if they're a penny each
you still own a thousand shares it's
when you sell it that's when you redeem
it for those pennies this is my second
bear market uh i mean bear market and
bull market right so when things are
good it's called the bull market when
things are not so good it's a bear
market
this is my second one and i gotta say
from from being through the first one
where i just i bought some bitcoin and
then [ __ ] went [ __ ] tanked
like crazy which one was tougher which
was this time tougher
this time was tougher this time was
tougher as far as
um because of the amount of money yeah
but the last time was tougher just
emotionally
uh because it was your first time it was
my first time because this one you had
optimism of you know what the value is
and it's gonna go you just
it's timing because i i was right there
with you where i'm like when is it gonna
happen
i know it's undervalued so in stocks
or in investments what you try to do is
you buy something that isn't
at its full potential yet for example
let's say
bitcoin right a lot of people are
speculating that bitcoin
can make a hundred grand be up to a
value of a hundred grand right
we've had bill gates say that we've had
uh john mcafee i mean bart quan said it
sometimes
green thinks there's a lot of people who
think well over fifty thousand dollars
each coin will be
so then you have to look at the scenario
isn't it currently valued at 11
000 as we speaks so i don't know it
might be like 20 or
5 i don't know whenever this goes up i
don't know what it's going to be because
it's
volatile meaning it swings up and down
it's [ __ ] crazy it's a it's a bipolar
creature it's so fun
but when what people will technically do
is they'll look
but they'll look they'll look at it and
they'll be like oh man
it's three thousand dollars oh it used
to be a thousand dollars
instead of seeing it as bill gates or
these top
guys that are that are studying these
things or whatever they'll be like yeah
it's supposed to be a hundred grand
eventually so people will look at it and
go um
yeah i'll put in 11 grand to make a
hundred grand
uh but then some people might see it and
say i've got 11 grand that's a lot of
money
right so or buy part of a bitcoin dude
you could buy a portion of it yeah
yeah for sure but i think that what
you're trying to do is buying someone
that isn't
worth its value yet so you're you're
buying it ahead hoping that it will go
up but you're not buying
blindly you're trying to make a
calculated risk
speculation a lot of these banks like
chase and all these hedge funds and
whatever they used to talk so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] about bitcoin
and then finds out the ceo of chase was
caught
with a big [ __ ] bitcoin stack and he
was so embarrassed he [ __ ] stepped
down from that whole [ __ ]
yeah drama yeah because all the people
were falsely like see
even chase says bitcoin's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
and then you find out that this guy is
buying bitcoin we're fighting the
marketplace though right you can buy
cheaper i mean that's that happens a lot
too what does that mean
like fear uncertainty doubt like they're
putting out something that makes people
go i don't want to buy this anymore yeah
so then let's say i got millions of
dollars right and i'm like man where am
i going to buy some more cheap bitcoin
oh i know what i'll do i'll tell nelson
because
my buddy nelson here he owns [ __ ] cnn
i'll be like hey nelson can you kind of
like tell the world how shitty bitcoin
is these days
sure bitcoin shitty man oh no it's
shitty cnn says it's shitty
let's sell yeah and he's like i'ma
[ __ ] buy some cheap ass bitcoin now
just use my drug dealers all that [ __ ]
but then you look at when drug dealers
get arrested you see these warehouses
full of cash
so it's like it's such a it's such an
optical thing
there's a lot of manipulation going on
but it's it's pretty it's a fun little
thing to do man i love
investing it's so beautiful right now i
am glad that i lost money the first time
i invested because
even though at that time i thought it
was the end of the world i
learned my lessons i wasn't emotional
you lost money on apple right
facebook oh facebook in college i
recently graduated i was like
hmm i don't know what we're gonna do
just yet so as we were hustling for jk
maybe i should invest some money
so i had like a car i sold it for 17 000
and then i bought a car for seven
thousand so i had 10k to play with
damn and then uh facebook was gonna have
their
first ipo which is initial public
offering and then i'm like hell yes once
in a lifetime opportunity you think
everything is once a lifetime
opportunity
um yeah if it's the first time for
everything yeah so
i bought uh facebook the server crashed
for like four to six hours the um
constantly because
everyone was trying to get facebook and
then i finally got in i think at like
29 bucks or something or 30 bucks and i
bought however much 10 000
worth was worth and then i'm like [ __ ]
yeah i got it
and then like because i don't understand
trends after you buy it it always dips
yeah
so a week two weeks three weeks four
weeks i'm like it's never gonna come up
and it went down to like i don't know
like 17 bucks or something and i'm like
no so i sold it no and then let me see
where's facebook oh no what is
facebook at right now what is it let's
see i don't know so you bought it at
20-something bucks and have they pulled
off their shares since then too
so i'll tell you how many shares i had i
had ten thousand dollars
yeah divided by and i'll tell you how
much facebook is worth
ten thousand divided by let's say thirty
bucks okay so i have 333 shares
333 yeah my favorite numbers hold on uh
well facebook's only set at 269 right
now but i don't know how many times
they've split their shares since then
that'd have been pretty sick yeah only
only 269 but that means that they
probably split their shares multiple
times since then so you
so i would have 90 000 extra dollars wow
90 000 out of your 10 grand yeah but i
was
i was so scared that's the markets man
they play with you but that's how a lot
of people
lose money in stocks though is being
short-sighted as an amateur you
you go oh it's all over and then you
freak out and then you sell it dude
people in my family told me to my face
crypto is dead and i'm like no this is a
market you're dead
yeah you're dead to me no but it's a
it's called a market cycle
but they treat it like it's just some
grand trend happening and it's just a
market cycle just like how
everything else has markets everything's
a cycle all the time
but now that now that i'm here i can say
i told you so it's very fun yeah because
last month we were just i don't know man
should we buy more like i don't know
i was hiding under the bed yeah and i'm
just kind of like
um i did tell my friends you look like a
genius though when your bed is right
because my friend texted me this morning
and he was like
dude this is crazy i thought you were
crazy when you did all of this
but now i realize you knew what you were
doing if you remember
why you bought high then you remember
why you can still buy low
nothing none of the fundamentals changed
about why we bought high right
and so now that we're killing it it just
it doesn't surprise me i'd always
believed because i knew why i bought it
there is a concept in gambling and poker
um
that i use now an investment and it's
and it's don't play with scared money
meaning like if you gotta use this money
this is the money that you play in poker
some people do this in gambling they're
like i need to make grant
so i'm gonna go to the casino we knew
people like that right
but then you make the worst decisions
you don't play risky
you don't play logical you play very
emotional and then
that's what happened with crypto i
played with
i put myself in scared money god damn it
you sure did you know why too you just
wanted to be up there with me with my
amount that i had
i that's the funniest part of the whole
i don't remember
i just remember i was being mad excited
and i just kept wanting to go
yeah yeah you also said if you cash out
you're gonna
put yourself back in scared money again
yes i will
i will but dude like you said your
friends are now being like yo you're a
genius dude and that's the greatest
feeling that's the feel yeah
are you talking about vase and den yup
he texted me this morning too yup and
did he call you a genius too no okay